SPEAKER: This demo highlights
one of our newest BigQuery
features, Time
Unit Partitioning.
This feature allows you to
organize time-based data
using flexible units of time,
ranging from an hour to a year.
To see this feature
in action, let's work
with the BigQuery public data
set on Wikipedia page views.
This data set contains a
timestamp column called
"datehour."
If you are familiar with
creating daytime partition
tables, you know that you can
use "daytime_trunc" and specify
a daytime column and a parameter
for the time component,
in this case, hour.
For this data set,
the Query Editor
warns us that the dataset does
not contain a column called
"daytime."
Recall from our review of
the dataset that it actually
contains a timestamp
column called "datehour."
To modify this query for
Time Unit Partitioning,
you can simply replace
"daytime_trunc"
with "timestamp_trunc,"
and "daytime"
column with the
"datehour" column.
With the time component
set as "hour,"
the query will create an
hourly partition table.
You can easily create
a daily partition table
by replacing "HOUR" with "DAY."
Last, you can create a daily
partition table with clustering
by adding "CLUSTER BY datehour."
Using these three
versions of the query,
I have created the tables
listed under a dataset called
"timeunit."
Taking a look at the details
of the hourly partition table,
you can see that it contains
just over 12.7 billion records
and that it is partitioned by
hour on the "datehour" column.
The details for the daily
partition table show the same
number of rows and that
it is partitioned by day
on the "datehour" column.
The daily partition table
with clustering shows similar
information, the difference
being that it is also clustered
on the "datehour" column.
To compare the performance of
these Time Unit Partitioning
schemes, let's run a few queries
to select some hourly data.
First, let's select
some data for a specific
one-and-a-half-hour window
from the daily partition table.
Note that the estimated
amount of data processed
for this query is 6 gigs.
While the query may
not take long to run,
selecting all data for that
one-and-a-half-hour window from
the daily partition table ended
up processing the entire 6 gigs
of data.
Let's run the same selection
on the hourly partition table
to see the difference
in performance.
On the hourly partition
table, the same query
is estimated to process
noticeably less data,
about 575 megs of data.
Running the query shows that,
indeed, it only processed
about 575 megs of data.
For comparison, let's
run the same query
on the daily partition
table with clustering.
Notice that the
estimated amount of data
processed for this
query is again 6 gigs.
Running this query highlights
that the hourly partition table
performed similarly to
a daily partition table
with clustering, but with a more
straightforward implementation.
For example, recall that the
estimate of data processed
for the daily
partition table was
6 gigs, the same as the
estimate for the daily partition
table with clustering, even
though the query on the cluster
table ended up
processing less data.
Limiting the selection
further to a 45-minute window
shows the true benefit
of hourly partitioning.
The query on the
daily partition table
still has to process
6 gigs of data.
However, the hourly
partition table
only has to process
281 megs of data.
Running the query shows that it
indeed only processed 281 megs.
Now that you have seen Time
Unit Partitioning in action,
we hope that you are
excited to try it out
on your time-based data.
Be sure to check out the
BigQuery docs to learn more.
And keep an eye
out for the release
notes to stay informed about
other exciting features headed
your way.